i Bobbie and I always tried I need a lot
of reassurance sometimes and the other
or last week I asked them hey like if I
got really really fat would you stay
with me he's like yeah as a matter of
fact if you I'd want I want you to gain
40 pounds like okay what if I lost like
one of my limbs would you stay with me
he's like yeah of course sweetie I know
I love you all the LA sounds like what
if like 60% of my body mostly my face
was burned because of course of course
of course so I show him a picture that I
did not show you a picture of a woman a
burn victim who recently got engaged to
her husband and what do you think he
said I asked him would you stay with me
if I look like this no I would she
that's the were mask and that's not
that's not you're still with her I'm
still with it you're loyal
yeah just put on a man yeah we're you
know one of those Halloween Mike Myers
Halloween a cocky mask or you can change
it up every day I do a different mask I
mix in all of a sudden you know you're
okay with that I'm okay with it
but I don't want because what happens
then is this okay
is is that then you have to kind of when
you work to dinner and then like I've
run into a friend then you have to
explain what happened but you don't have
to explain the mask oh it's like I don't
think before that what should art scene
that way whatever you know so be like
yeah but yeah I mean no I don't know I
don't know what that's like maybe I will
maybe I won't you don't think I would
what about you Clara Bobby gets his arm
burned his whole arm burned he already
looks like a burn victim okay he loses
an eye weld of course yeah but if I lost
an eye and if I was in a fire I wouldn't
want to live I mean I'm depressed as it
is and I'd this is a sad thing to say
and I want to be let me say something if
I was if I couldn't walk or I couldn't
feel my dick yet from a car accident I
really don't know if I would stay
if I was blind I don't know I might just
kill myself no no just listen I don't
know I'm asking the universe would I
would I not I don't know but my opinion
now would be maybe I would you know it's
funny that you say that and I think
maybe I've mentioned it in a previous
episode but when my my grandfather
always used to say the same thing he
always used to say I don't want to live
past 60 I don't want to live past 60
because it's like what kind of quality
of life am I gonna have after that
mm-hmm
this was like mmm 25 years ago or 20
years ago or something like I always
used to remember this and when he was 59
he got diagnosed with lung cancer and I
only had six months to live yeah so on
his 60th 60th birthday we had like a
little Backhouse for him my dad set up a
little Hospital studying with his oxygen
and you know his bed and everything and
he was speaking with my dad and mom and
he was just shattered talking about why
God would take his life so soon I want
to live I I still want to live he tried
to fight his diagnosis he really really
could not accept that he was gonna die
and he died at the age of 60 yeah but
that's different I'm not saying that if
I want to live forever no what I'm
saying is he wasn't in a fire no listen
what no what I'm saying is he didn't
want to live past 60 ever because he
just didn't think like the quality of
life he just didn't want to be an old
guy he never wanted me I felt the same
way every years but then I said watch
the olders for youngers yeah but what
I'm saying is is that okay so what
you're saying to me is that he changed
it too and he wanted to live he
absolutely wanted to live okay if I was
in a fire maybe see that's the thing
I don't know I've never been in a fire I
think that my dad was very similar to I
mean he the last year of his life he had
a gangrenous foot you know and he was in
a lot of pain and he was already in his
cell I think 79 and you would think that
yeah put me out of my [ __ ] misery and
he coated probably six times that year
mean
it means to say they had to like
resuscitate him and bring him back to
life but he kept telling the hospital
you know if I if I if I flatline I want
to be resuscitated each time oh he
wasn't a DNR DNR do-not-resuscitate in
your papers or in the hospital if you're
admitted they always know when if or
when you do not want to be resuscitated
to let you die but my dad kept wanting
to live and I mean he was no longer
mobile he was in a [ __ ] was [ __ ]
himself he was completely incontinent he
had a foot that was charcoal black but
it was enough for him to just see his
daughters and even little things like
eat lunch with him by his bedside while
he was getting fed you know like not
real food anymore
but it was enough for him so people do
want to you don't know how you're gonna
feel until you're right I don't know but
also I might be similar I think if I'm
in a vegetative state like I probably
and but if my mind you know like walk in
syndrome where your mind is fully intact
but your body is completely like
vegetative I would want to be put out
for sure okay well then you have your
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah but not over a
[ __ ] eye okay one I know I wouldn't I
want to live after one I when I find two
eyes two eyes no two eyes I probably
would even when I one year I'd learn I
would be able to do it I'd learn like
yeah this is what I like you know you
just have to learn like echolocation
like the Dolf is a girl yeah but if I
was in a fire you know what I would do I
would live in a forest and want to be
like the Bobby which like the boats
right and have like folklore you're the
urban man right I'm the urban myth oh
[ __ ] and I would do cooking crazy [ __ ]
such as when white people camping I just
do kind of things when they're sleeping
I just maybe I'll inject up I'll find
some sort of like going out there that
make them pass out okay you know what's
really we can we can we pause real quick
yeah can you put that dog in her crate
you put great Georgie because she's
gonna keep barking the rest of the time
thank you so you take the ointment you
injected on white people I don't know
you what happens after they fall asleep
is already asleep but I would do stuff
like like
just they built all the tents all their
clothes
everything's is gone so there is
completely may wake up naked no day
nikon right okay all right okay and they
I dig I dig the ditch right
and then but their heads are on the of
the ground [ __ ] that's some scary stuff
right yeah I wouldn't kill them right
and I would have like some sort of
animals about like um just deer will
coyote coyote poop
there's smeared all over their faces
right and then I would probably make
these little Bobby Lee statues out of
wood and they'll be on top of the coyote
poop I have a little pole right and they
would just know that they die Bobby what
you got them yeah I from love whatever
what the [ __ ] did you do it towards I
think that is actually one of his like
dreams
I mean fantasies he would never do it
rely in urban legend no to force
inseminate people with his sperm like
with a turkey baster we Lily went from a
jetty people to fall asleep with some
people at spur you are thought but juice
I that's where I thought like you for
the Bobby which like putting your jizz
inside people who's just impregnating
people but only guys in there but all oh
I want a cream pie butthole keep my
buttholes
big heads I think dogs gonna drive me
crazy then no whatever she's parking
ambiance sorry yeah it's driving me
[ __ ] crazy
let's pause until she's done barking
[Music]